You may have thought that because Zack Snyder's
Justice League is almost here there wouldn't
be any more trailers coming, but you'd be
wrong.
On the afternoon of Sunday, March 14th, HBO
Max released a new trailer for the film formerly
known as the "Snyder Cut," and there's a lot
of new stuff to gawk at.
In particular, we see a lot more of Ray Porter's
Darkseid than we have previously, including
the powerful New God expressing his hunger
to rule over "all of existence."
“I have turned worlds to dust.
All of existence shall be mine.”
But along with big, explosive moments of heroes
warring with villains and armies clashing,
there are a handful of small details you likely
missed upon first viewing.
A number of shots in the trailer show us classic
DC Comics characters we hadn't seen before,
and — just like one of the most famous Justice
Leaguers — none of them are from anywhere
near our zip code, our hemisphere, or any
place in our particular corner of the solar
system.
While some reports about Snyder's original
plans for Justice League claimed Darkseid
wouldn't confront the eponymous team of do-gooders
himself, a couple of moments in the trailer
have us wondering whether or not the ruler
of Apokolips might not be taking a much more
direct hand in things than previously believed.
Here are the small details you missed in the
(likely final) trailer for Zack Snyder's Justice
League.
Blink and you'll miss it, but one of the most
interesting moments in the latter section
of the new trailer comes at around 2:03.
Very briefly we get a shot of a woman — who
may be Diane Lane's Martha Kent, Kal-El's
adoptive mother — and her eyes are glowing
bright red.
Of course, even if that is Martha Kent, being
from Krypton isn't contagious so why would
her eyes be glowing like that?
The most likely answer: While that may be
Diane Lane, it isn't Martha Kent — it's
J'onn J'onnz, better known as the Martian
Manhunter.
In January 2021, actor Harry Lennix confirmed
a long held fan theory that General Swanwick
- the character Lennix plays in both 2013's
Man of Steel and 2016's Batman v. Superman:
Dawn of Justice – is the Martian Manhunter
in disguise.
At the same time, Lennix said he would finally
be revealed as J'onn J'onzz in Zack Snyder's
Justice League.
The alien hero has a long list of powers in
the comics including flight, super strength,
telepathy, and — relevantly to this investigation
— shapeshifting.
It isn't a huge stretch to imagine J'onzz
taking on the form of Martha Kent.
Either that, or Diane Lane's dealing with
some brutal allergies.
Martian Manhunter isn't the only alien hero
the new trailer gives us a first look at.
At around 0:57, in shots that appear to be
from the battle between the forces of Earth
and those of Apokolips in the distant past,
we get a glimpse of a member of the Green
Lantern Corps.
who looks nothing at all like Ryan Reynolds.
That doesn't mean he's completely unfamiliar,
however — at least not to long-time fans
of DC.
Judging by this lantern's appearance, there's
a good chance this is Yalan Gur, a Green Lantern
who's introduced in a flashback in 1991's
Green Lantern #19.
Gifted with a ring that has no weaknesses,
Yalan Gur becomes overconfident and dies for
his error.
Will Zack Snyder's Justice League delve significantly
into this deep canon?
Will we actually get to see Gur's downfall
brought to life on screen?
Time will tell, but this kind of addition
would be certain to delight hardcore fans.
At about 01:37 into the trailer we see something
that's never before been portrayed in live
action — the deadly Omega Beams of Darkseid.
Their zig-zagging pattern is unmistakable,
and Darkseid's target may very well be Jason
Momoa's Aquaman.
Whoever it is, they seem to be swimming, and
moments before this shot we get snippets from
the underwater battle between Aquaman and
Darkseid's lieutenant Steppenwolf.
That may not be the last that we see of Omega
Beams, either.
A few seconds later in the trailer, we see
red energy beams firing at the Batmobile,
and at around 02:07 we get more red beams
firing at Batman himself.
It isn't clear if these last two shots emanate
from Darkseid.
They don't share the trademark zig-zag pattern
from what we can tell, and there are plenty
of other possible origins in a film like Justice
League for crazy sci-fi lasers.
Regardless, just the first shot of the Omega
Beams is intriguing.
When Kevin Smith first started spilling the
beans on what he knew about Zack Snyder's
plans for Justice League, the story was that
while Darkseid would have shown up, it wouldn't
have been until toward the end of the film.
What we see in this latest trailer could suggest
Zack Snyder's Justice League will give us
a Darkseid who's more involved throughout.
Fans won't have to wait long to confirm all
this speculation.
Zack Snyder's Justice League will attempt
to crash the HBO Max servers on March 18th,
2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about DC heroes
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.